Columbia land of flavor in color but if
you know about the incredibly rich and
unusual fruits this country has to offer
thanks to its biodiversity the land
produces delicacies like the
prehistoric-looking guanabana and the
mysterious Mago steam and that brings us
here this is not your typical grocery
store produce section
this is below keema welcome to Bogota is
quintessential market this is the place
to find the most mysterious looking
strange flavored fruits across the
palate minimalist romário real Mariko in
dead flutist tank on a remote island
iguana wanna wanna wanna assume a
furutaka Sylve para prepararse para
prepararse for stress excuse Luna put'em
we are macro muchos casita
well they are comfo seriously never mind
wander us Arabic any external campus or
via our service is Alvaro Makino say no
se puede comprar una mejor modo your
kids walk in a circle okay Martin or
window that because este es el Magos he
knows
[Music]
una puta carryin a maraquita Calima yes
a photo you see akka port where is
morale Holloway II por dentro is Blanca
hello Alan yeah I see that
[Music]
PTT now say you're on cereal banners LEC
awesome so when they order protamine
hombres Alexander SS it supporting
[Music]
artists to rise for more manga inter a
larger we do say we Rick Delos Yoshioka
names our winner - Rolla cancel do the
people we told you en la Rey de la cosa
follow kamau is a special place bursting
with color and flavor offering the world
an irreplaceable array of nectarous
gifts of course as long as they're in
the seat
you